the brain is probably the most
sophisticated processor in the universe
often people with paralysis will have a
brain that is fully functional and the
reason they're unable to move is because
the cable that carries the information
from their brain to their body is cut
what we're trying to do is build a
device called brain gate and brain gate
is actually a physical bridge that
connects the outside world back to the
data that's trapped inside the brain the
whole history of neuroscience is tied up
in being able to create a brain machine
interface the big problem really for us
although there are many challenges is to
be able to make sense of all of that
information that's coming out of the
brain now the stuff that comes out is
really complicated and this is where the
science of massive data is really
critical to us each little neuron each
little brain cell emits a tiny
electrical impulse and it's sort of a
dit dit dit impulse kind of signal so
that the code that comes out is
effectively like a Morse code we can
disco today I want to move laughter I
want to move right we use a baby aspirin
sized chip that has 100 hair-thin
electrodes that get implanted in the
brain all the bone and skin is closed
leaving only a connector about the size
of a penny that sticks through the skin
which is where we attach and get the
signals from the brain so if we could
understand everything about the brain
what impact would it have feeling and
desire and the dream is that the person
it's not about the technology it's about
the way people use it
this isn't wacky science fiction in 2006
Matthew Nagle was the first person to
have a brain gauge system and here's
Matthew using the brain gate to play a
video game we even hooked him up to a
mechanical motorized hand he hadn't
controlled anything in more than two
years at that point we looked out any
went opened the hand open and he went
holy it was really that was a
wonderful moment with him you know that
it truly showed even though it didn't
really do anything important it was a
demonstration that you know small things
for people who are otherwise fully
incapacitated is really a big advance we
who are able-bodied forget that a lot of
our dignity is tied up and being able to
do things for ourselves
I had a degenerative bone disease as a
child so I spent some time in a
wheelchair and with a brace that did
give me a little flavor of what it's
like to be limited in mobility the
essence of our humanity is
by that kind of life we're doing so do
the first steps in restoring dignity
going from being able to do nothing to
being able to do something one of the
more rewarding aspects of this is
working with these extraordinary people
who have really overcome tremendous
adversity have a strong will to go on
and do things in their lives this
processing in our brain that occurs is
some kind of computation that we don't
understand and that is maybe one of the
greatest puzzles that's ever confronted
us